[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you know what this is from if you didn't
read the text on the screen it's the
unforgettable ending of Raiders of the
Lost Ark it imagines this vast Warehouse
filled with Untold government secrets
now while that was pure fiction the
truth is there is a top secret
government storage facility down in
Virginia's Shenandoah Valley but with a
high-tech Twist of Scott McFarland takes
us for a visit near the mountains in
rural Winchester Virginia more than 60
miles from the nation's capital inside a
classified Federal facility the FBI has
deployed a team
of robots an agency that for more than a
century has uncovered crime and secrets
has built a home for all the FBI Files
detailing those crimes and secrets it's
just a little bit smaller than two
football fields full of Records yes
it's a lot yep 7.4 million and to move
the unparalleled piles of paper they've
built and set in motion a team of more
than 100 robotic helpers it sounds like
the world's biggest library in in some
instances it is we have a lot of
information here a major investment an
upgrade for the bureau which previously
kept its piles of files and storage
rooms and locked boxes at its dozens of
field offices Nationwide they now have
one Clearinghouse with hard copies of
the files from thousands of cases from
probes of Al Capone to the Olympic Park
bombing 911 to the assassination of JFK
these Case Files have been collected
from every community in America every
FBI field office across the U.S there
are a lot of them they fill 360
000 of these gray crates and as more
cases close the files come here we
designed this to work just as simple as
self-checkout at the grocery store for
bar coding scanning and deposit once the
organization sees the value of having
our records readily accessible
retrievable and digitized you get them
quicker the agency is hoping this speeds
the work of agents who are investigating
new crimes every old case File stored
here can be retrieved and digitized and
sent to agents Across America in 10
minutes if needed we freed up warehouses
we freed out square footage and we have
people doing the most important work in
the field that they need to be doing
which is working those cases a new
modern era for an agency still
synonymous with J Edgar Hoover as the
G-Man are now getting the help of robots
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Scott
McFarland in Winchester Virginia
I didn't see much security there if I
were Scott I would have been like who
killed gfk
okay I have a feeling the security was
there the security was a hundred bucks
is 360
000 crates I'm sure there's other
mysteries in there that could be solved
if someone digs in deep enough don't let
Michelle Miller in there